en la mayoría de las reacciones redox
una sustancia es reducida mientras que
otra sustancia es oxidada sin embargo
hay algunas reacciones redox en las que
la misma sustancia puede ser oxidada y
reducida en la misma reacción ya éstas
les llamamos reacciones de desproporción
aunque también pueden ser conocidas como
reacciones de dis mutación y bueno por
aquí tenemos uno de los ejemplos más
famosos de una reacción de desproporción
que se trata de la descomposición del
peróxido de hidrógeno así es que por
aquí en los reactivos tenemos peróxido
de hidrógeno el cual si le agregas un
catalizador como yoduro de potasio se
transforma en agua y oxígeno así es que
pues vamos a asignar los estados de
oxidación para todos estos oxígenos
vamos a empezar por el oxígeno del agua
y bueno hay principalmente dos formas de
asignar estados de oxidación la primera
es la de la memorización es memorizar de
todas
reglas que vienen en cualquier libro de
química general y estas reglas nos dicen
que el oxígeno en una molécula de agua
tiene un estado de oxidación -2 y por
otro lado cuando tenemos una molécula de
oxígeno o2 el estado de oxidación del
oxígeno es cero
y por acá resulta que el peróxido de
hidrógeno es uno de esos extraños' casos
en los que el estado de oxidación del
oxígeno es menos uno por supuesto que te
puedes memorizar todas las reglas acerca
de la asignación de estados de oxidación
o la otra opción para encontrar un
estado de oxidación es dibujar los
diagramas de puntos de las moléculas y
pensar en la electro negatividad ahorita
vamos a hacer eso vamos a empezar otra
vez con la molécula de agua y bueno
sabemos que estos dos enlaces están
formados por dos electrones cada uno
y también sabemos que el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que los hidrógenos
entonces podemos pensar que los
electrones de estos enlaces se están
yendo con el oxígeno y vamos a tratar a
estos enlaces como si fueran un enlace
iónico aunque en realidad no es un
enlace iónico así es que el oxígeno se
queda con todos los electrones de estos
enlaces y el oxígeno normalmente tiene 6
electrones de valencia entonces ponemos
un 6 por aquí al 6 le vamos a restar 8 y
6 menos 8 es menos 2 y así es que de
esta forma obtenemos el estado de
oxidación del oxígeno que es menos 2 lo
cual coincide con lo que tenemos por
aquí pero eso de poner los diagramas de
puntos y pensar en la electro
negatividad te ayuda a entender un poco
más eso de los estados de oxidación
bueno ahora vamos a volver a sacar el
estado de oxidación pero
y ahora de estos oxígenos en esta
molécula de o2 que tenemos aquí un doble
enlace y cada uno de estos enlaces tiene
dos electrones
ahora como es un doble enlace entre dos
oxígenos estos dos átomos tienen
exactamente la misma electrón
negatividad por lo cual se van a
repartir a los electrones en partes
iguales lo que hay así es que este
oxígeno se queda con estos electrones y
este oxígeno se queda con estos otros
por lo que el estado de oxidación de
cualquiera de estos dos oxígenos es
pensamos en cuántos electrones de
valencia tiene generalmente un oxígeno
generalmente tiene 6 y está rodeado por
así es que 6 menos 6 nos da 0
el estado de oxidación de un oxígeno en
una molécula o 2 es 0 y ahora vamos con
el peróxido de hidrógeno
tenemos aquí estos tres enlaces cada uno
tiene dos electrones vamos a sacar el
estado de oxidación de este oxígeno el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno y por lo tanto se va a quedar
con estos dos electrones ahora cuando
llegamos por aquí como tenemos dos
átomos iguales 2 oxígenos son
exactamente igual de electro negativos
por lo cual se van a repartir uno y uno
de los electrones generalmente el
oxígeno tiene 6 electrones de valencia a
su alrededor pero en esta molécula el
oxígeno tiene 7 electrones de valencia a
su alrededor
entonces restamos 7 y nos queda 67 menos
el estado de oxidación del oxígeno en el
peróxido de hidrógeno es menos 1 es
cierto que si ya tienes memorizados los
estados de oxidación es mucho más rápido
pero dibujar los diagramas de puntos
de ellos sacar los estados de oxidación
puede ser muy útil así es que ya tenemos
los estados de oxidación y podemos
ponernos a analizar qué es lo que pasa
en esta reacción
por ejemplo tomemos uno de estos
oxígenos de este peróxido de hidrógeno
oxígeno que tiene un estado de oxidación
de menos 1 y digamos que en la reacción
este oxígeno se transforma en uno de los
oxígenos de la molécula o 2 se
transforma en uno de los oxígenos de la
molécula o 2 pero los oxígenos en la
molécula de oxígeno tienen un estado de
oxidación cero
y así es que este oxígeno está pasando
de un estado de oxidación -1 a un estado
de oxidación cero por lo que está
perdiendo un electrón y aquí podemos
recordar la mnemotecnia pp
que es pérdida de electrones es
oxidación y sabemos que este oxígeno
está siendo oxidado porque este oxígeno
está siendo oxidado y bueno en lugar de
usar a p también pudimos haber dicho oye
está aumentando su estado de oxidación
entonces está siendo oxidado porque hay
porque estamos pasando de menos 1 a 0
eso es incrementar el estado de
oxidación por otro lado en esta reacción
también sucede que algunos de los
oxígenos del peróxido de hidrógeno uno
de los oxígenos que tienen un estado de
oxidación de menos 1 termina siendo el
oxígeno de una molécula de agua
pero los oxígenos en las moléculas de
agua tienen un estado de oxidación -2
así es que en la reacción se transforme
en un oxígeno que tiene un estado de
oxidación -2 como los oxígenos del agua
y entonces se trata de una reducción o
sea una disminución en el estado de
oxidación porque ahí estamos pasando de
menos 1 a menos 2 está decreciendo el
estado de oxidación y entonces se trata
de una reducción así es que tenemos una
reacción aquí en la que la misma
sustancia se oxida y se reduce o sea que
se trata de una reacción de
desproporción o también conocida como
reacción de dis mutación